BEBEASASLELEY.Y.
LALAY-Y-UPUP R RIGIGHTHT  HAHAN.
NONO   H HIMIM  STSTOPOP
JAJACKCK'S'S B BEEEENN G GOIOIN!
McMcDEDERMRMOTOTTT T TRYRYINING.
>>>> W Walalt:t: T THEHERERE D.
JAJACKCK T TOO  POPORZRZININGIG.
FIFIRERESS U UPP N NUMUMBEBERSR
THTHEYEY  HEHEARARD.D.
SHSHOTO---- S SHOHOT T ISIS G G!
.
OFOFFF T THEHE B BACACKK S SIDI
MAMARKRKKAKANENENN W WIDIDEE  O.
WOWON'N'TT   T THEHE
>>>> M Mikike:e: J JARARRERETTT
REREVIVIEWEW..LILIKEKE..
>>>> M Mikike:e: H HOLOLIDIDAYA
NWNWABABAA A ALLLL O OVEVERR J .
PUPULLLLUPUP J JUMUMPEPERR F FR.
>>>> M Mikike:e: J JACACKK INI.
POPORZRZININGIGISS
SHSHOTOT B BANANKSKS I ITT  QUQ.
MAMADEDE A A S STATATETEMEMENTN.
POPORZRZININGIGISS P PUTUTSS U E
KNKNICICKSKS T TOO G GETET O OF
BABALLLL..
>>>> M Mikike:e: O OFF T THEHE .
THTHEYEY'R'RE I